ciao ciao ragazzi nuova challenge sempre
con la ruota questa volta abbiamo paura
che la mia ruota in più abbiamo i
brufoletti 3g dio ci sarà con la ruota
delle torture deciderà come schiacceremo
i brufoli non ne possiamo di molto
evidente rischio forse allora andiamo
innanzitutto ad aprire bustina dei
brufolo ti vediamo come sono e poi
andiamo a mettersi rinforza e iniziare
la salle salvaggio timberlake
se volete vedere attrezzata inzuppate
come questa
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
iniziamo subito allora innanzitutto vi
faccio vedere la volta che abbiamo
preparato per fare la challenge se
capita questo simbolo qua vuol dire che
dovremmo schiacciare più gruppo li
possibile in 30 secondi
se invece capita questo simbolo qua
dovremmo schiacciare i brufoli il più
possibile da bendati e capita questo
invece dovremmo schiacciare i brufoli
dobbiamo schiacciarsi brufoli a vicenda
quindi io dovrò schiacciarle vitale
vitale dovrà schiacciarli m s capita
questa dovremmo scherzare più brufoli
possibile con solo una mano siamo adesso
ai gruppo lotti allora sono in allegato
alla rivista
se guardate che carina questa rivista
con questo cagnolino con la maschera per
il dito bellissimi potete trovare in
edicola il costo di 3 ore 90 per la
rivista con l'allegato dei cru folosofia
un po come questa rivista allora
innanzitutto carinissimo che ci sono
consigli per la cura della pelle quindi
il proprio in tema
i brufoli tra l'altro a me piace un
sacco schiacciarmi brufoli anche se non
dovrei quindi ogni volta che ho voglia
di essermi brucoli userò il gruppo lotti
adesso ecco qua vedete se sono tante
pubblicità sulla pelle consigli
trucchetti c'è anche un quiz sulla cura
della pelle
ad esempio dove la nostra pelle più
sottile sulla schiena sulle palpebre o
sulle braccia secondo me sulle palpebre
però non sono sicura secondo te anche se
con noi ha copiato vietata questa è la
rivista super carina e ora andiamo ad
aprire l'allegato gruppo fox troppo
curiosa è che i nostri brufolosi che poi
andremo a pizzicarsi in partecipata ci
sono 10 brufolo ti ho già voglia di
schiacciarli incredibile
[Musica]
non vedo velo di provarle omar avital e
sei pronto a farti schizza di brucoli a
spiazzarmi intrecciamo iniziamo subito
che si deve scherzare più tubi o qualche
domanda ormai sono un'esperta perché mi
piacerebbe non sono iscritti
dobbiamo quindi in pratica basta svelare
qua ecco qua diventa appiccicoso un
adesivo dove lo metto
ammette qua l'altra proposta gigante o
che questa è anche una bella idea per
fare degli scherzi agli amici o ai
genitori ma anche se fai tipo scalzi
dopanti e confronti per il primo era un
paese la mamma mia mi posso fidare carta
forno e setoso gira malcapitato non
lavorano non vedo non lo schiacciano
finire in un minuto quanti brufoli ebri
fumo
riuscirà piazzarmi invitare siamo pronti
in pratica timer un minuto imposto il
tie break point è stato il timer suo
minuto non lo sposo e sposa si quasi un
palco al motto morbido scherzar midolo 1
vediamo io con te riuscito a piazzarmi
non vedrà mai capito cos'è bravata più
solido venduto tanto guardare
ok sono bendata pro alcuni gruppi sono
coperti quindi mi metto più sotto il
sito esposti di bruno via pediano delle
star direzione la data è piu forte ci
sei quasi si dei vasi conoscendo eccolo
sta uscendo si vedono vero uscito
guardate ora ha sancito si sono però
almeno non è schizzato via stato troppo
divertendovi sentire anche vitale vede
la luce lo mette la band a buy deciso da
line ma che figata
vai fiate null altro jazz jazz jazz
piazze che tutti lo scambio cabrio più
beverly cazzo scherzo scritto dovrei
esser riuscito
quanto l'altra poi fai mai mai accaduto
per i due allora siamo 2 1 per che anzi
tre perché ci sei riuscito a
schiacciarli quel vantaggio 3 a 1 che vi
capita come così con di questa volta 30
secondi oddio però almeno posso guardare
posso usare due mani quindi quando uno
specchio quindi guarderò quadri a sutri
psico questo lo screzio però no questo
qua 18 dice no a 12v di 87
[Musica]
esistiamo 3 a 2 rimasti pochi brufoli
quindi vediamo cos'altro si capitaneria
con una mano ce la farai
no ci prova ma aspetta fantastico no
un altro primato comitato promotore
formato
vi siamo 4 a 2 vediamo cosa mi capita a
me adesso via
a 30 secondi nome dai un altro un altro
caso un altro questo no questo questo
caso scoppiò bianca perché ce la fa a 46
vincerà granata tentativo si prende mai
no da 6 a 3 dai dai che ce la faccia non
abbiamo cambiato in questo piano broker
in un angolo per il ministro piacciono
tutto in un angolo non ce l'ho fatta da
farah dove stavamo prossimo dynamics
quando lo fa è perché c'è la pressione
del tempo noto come questo io se riesco
a vincere
giravamo cosa mi facciano 30 secondi
quindi siamo ancora l'aria è molto
oramai siamo in quattro a quattro
vediamo se riesco allora io ne ho uno
due tre quattro e cinque è pronti via
questo questo questo questo questo lo so
che ti ammazzo
oddio guarda tutto che devono sbrigare
un altro questo fa cosa che facciamo uno
con l'altro se io questo siamo 5 a 4
quindi forse vinco io ma mancano ancora
tre giorni quindi speriamo bene dai si
stanno parlando i brufoli premiamo 30
secondi di cambiare mai a disposizione
due dita e lo specchio due dita allora
con lo speck e te la puoi fare tutto in
un albero deve metterlo troppo grande in
tutto è nato tutto in alto mettilo by
dal no b day
[Musica]
[Applauso]
alla fine siamo turno a causa di quelle
che siamo cinque a cinque momenti
quest'azione di romani vedremo chi vince
chi è il mago proposto a piazzarsi di
più e schiacciasse lì a vicenda quindi
io devo schiacciarli a te sperando che
riesce a schiacciare ok vediamo questo
fai vai a testa tra piazzato uno
produrre di poter spezzare questo non
soltanto divertentissimo smettono lia
scherzo l'app al corriere il campanello
[Musica]
il segreto è tutto dire si può
presentarsi al 12
questo percorso dopo mia mentalità
valerica divertenti l'ultimatum a rete
non farò domani mattina sara pizi
comunque ad evitare tagli a tutti tutti
avete visto che sono riuscita a
piazzarlo in un altro figlio victor 6 a
1 proviamo a piazzarli liberare questi
brufolo ti fanno morire dal ridere o
versata bresca ti schiaccia un bruno
bosco veramente che traccia né il troppo
divertente vi consiglio di prendervi e
provarla con industrialmente con i
vostri genitori con i vostri non viene
dimostrata troppo divertente
oppure potete andare al corriere noi
popoli fa ancora oggi mi piace
schiacciarvi brufoli mettete questi e
schiacciate questo così non danneggiata
per ora fateci sapere se vi è piaciuta
prefazione se volete vi magari la
rifacciamo in un altro modo di tesi come
lasciate un bel live ricordo che fosse
saputo trovarli in pellicola in allegato
al magazine
ora mi lasciano un po a 4 castellini
pubblicare per vedere ora ci divertiremo
a spiazzare tutti gli altri cliccate
sulla casa in linea che preferite perché
sono pronto e buona visione
[Musica]